so bankers are basically people who help
people sell companies and help people
buy companies and when you sell a
company for like anything north probably
50 million they likely have a banker and
i've been contacting bankers and my
pitch to them is this hey i'm thinking
about starting a company in this space
you've sold a few companies in this
space tell me everything about why
the this company was bought as well as
what the opportunities are that the
buyer what they were looking for
and uh maybe in five or ten years i'll
let you sell my company and i've been
able to line up meetings doing this
and anyway
genius and
um
i've been a part of one or two of those
types of conversations and i was like oh
wow these guys are like vaults filled
with gold
[Music]
i i met a famous person this weekend um
i went and saw jimmy uh is it yang or
wang um the comedian uh i think jimmy oh
yang or something oh yeah well it's
jimmy oh i forget his last name but he's
uh what was his character in silicon
valley jin yang
yeah and he's a comedian and he was an
awesome guy and my friend is dating him
bri
and uh
funny in person or not
yeah he's awesome he was awesome like
comedy and funny like you just talking
to me like were you like
wow this person should be a comedian if
they weren't
no he was just really insightful and he
had like really good strong opinions and
he told stories well i mean i think you
could actually do it if you were to sit
down and write a
a bit i actually think that you have the
same traits uh but no he was just a
really nice thoughtful guy but he was
like legit famous to where everywhere we
went people would talk to him and
it was pretty pretty cool to see and i
imagine quite annoying for him because
the people who are fans of him because
he he doesn't actually talk like that
you know he's american right right and
but
yeah well they are fans of him
particularly the asian community they
love him um because uh well he just like
he's like representing nicely but
basically they come up to like like a
white guy came up to him and kind of
said something a little inappropriate
and it was like rooted in like the
silicon valley show right and i like
they think that he has an accent and
things like that and that's super
annoying particularly in awesome where
there's tons of like white bros so i
imagine that could be annoying but he
was legit famous and it was kind of cool
to see when you're around people who are
like you know famous in their world
do you
how do you act do you like
do you go
door a treat them like a normal person
in fact almost disregard their fame
be
nerd out about you know asking them a
zillion questions about you know the
show and what blah blah like you know
basically to ask them all the questions
they probably heard before but with
enthusiasm or see something else what do
you do dude so i do i i do b but i do it
in a very direct way kind of like the
podcasts where where it could tell that
i'm like really confident but i'm asking
questions up that everyone wants to know
so i'm like so you're like kind of
nagging them
yeah yeah so it's like so what's it like
here's a tiny example i've got a friend
of a friend who had cancer and he lost
his leg and when i first saw him i was
like what's going on man um
are you crushing it at pull-ups because
you're lighter now like how many pounds
did you lose off that leg
and he like really quickly opened up
because he was like oh you just got that
out you got it we got it all the way
it's not mixing like it's not here but
you're also uh
not making a huge deal out of it yeah
yeah yeah and so that's like how i
usually when i'm with famous people so
i'm like so what's it like you're pretty
famous is that cool or is it bad
like just
very direct and i typically find that it
makes people lighten up and they and
they'll and you
you are making them in a sense but
you're also like congratulating them and
they really will just open up you're
like
you're better looking in person i watch
the show
yeah yeah
you're way taller than i thought
yeah you're not nearly as slight of bill
as i was expecting
yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know yeah it's like uh
you know i don't care what people say i
think you're great dude my
brother-in-law has the best celebrity
move
um he
see if he sees a celebrity he greets
them like a long lost friend
so he'll see like we saw mike tyson and
he'll be like
mike what's up man how you been and
he'll go dap them up and be like because
seeing you he'll just like keep going
and they're just like do i know this guy
where did i be like be like george yo
how's houston ah george and then he'll
like just keep going and like just he'll
just make it seem like
they are they're just reconnecting
rather than meeting for the first time
and i thought what a hack what an
amazing hack because these people meet
tons of people so they didn't they don't
remember and so they'll automatically go
with your assumption that you like sort
of know each other or your equals in
some way peers in some way
you ever uh have you ever been to a
restaurant and the owner walks around
just greeting people and asking how
things are of course yeah
that is well i had a friend that told me
he used to pick up women that way where
he was just like i would approach this
with the attitude like i wouldn't act
like i was the owner but in my head i
would act like the owner how's everybody
doing here yeah and i would just and i
had that energy and i was able to meet
so many people with that
restaurant owner energy dude that's yeah
good
it's a good one
and so i like at hustle con when we're
hosting hustle account or when you and i
are hosting one of our events like you
you kind of know everyone knows who you
are and and so you kind of know that you
have the feeling where you can just walk
up to talk to anyone and they'll know
what's up right you have that energy
when you're trying to meet girls and
it's the best
dude that's so good like i'm just gonna
start wearing like a small dish towel
and my waist and go to restaurants and
just yeah just just walk around just
have a drink and just be walking around
you know greeting each table making sure
everything's going smoothly for them
[Laughter]
and you're not lying you're not telling
them
you assumed based on my big restaurant
energy here
um all right bro i got a few interesting
things to run by you do you have did you
have a lot left over from last time yeah
i kind of did can i tell you about one
yeah i don't know like business slash
idea this niche that's like got my
attention right now so
um i did i talked about this the other
day i went to that the blippi show did i
tell you about this no all right so
so do you know who blippi is have you
ever heard of blippi i don't know what
that is no all right so like remember
like back there we had barney or like
you know uh like pee wee herman or
whatever he's like it's like it's a dude
so he kind of looks like peter herman or
whatever but he's more like a barney or
you know um sesame street style show so
basically there's a guy who went on
youtube created this brand called blippi
and he um
he's entertaining so he'd be like oh and
by the way the funny thing that he does
is there's no like set he just goes into
like um hey we're at the aquarium but
they just go in like after 9pm it's like
closed down and so it's just they have
it all to themselves like hey we're here
in las vegas at this rock climbing
studio
and so he just uses that to film his
thing but he gives it a shout out at the
beginning of the video the video gets
like 40 million views so it's like you
know
it's worth it to let these guys film
there and he just like goes around and
he'll basically just play with toys he'd
be like i'm added abandoned chuck e
cheese and he'll go play with a bunch of
toys and there's like music and whatever
overlaid and it's the same guy i'm
looking at him now it's the same guy
every single time it is except for as he
blew up and got famous then they
switched him out with just a stunt
double for a bit and so like that guy's
like a substitute teacher sometimes and
then sometimes blippi comes back uh but
like the main guy is the main guy he
wears his outfits like this blue outfit
with his orange glasses he like always
looks the same so anyways my daughter
loved blippi we used to watch a ton of
bloopy
and all of a sudden we see this ad that
says um blippi like the live show is
coming to oakland and so we were like oh
and so
instantly my wife buys tickets for for
all of us in the family we go to this
thing last weekend
and it's it's at the same place you did
hustle con so it's at the paramount
theater and
it is packed like you know hustle khan
was like you know
sold out ish this was like sold out sold
out like all even the back shitty seat
is like sold out
and it's full of parents and their kids
and then there's this like this they
basically just created like a little
play like a little mini musical one hour
because kids don't have that long of an
attention span and it's just kind of
like music and like you know lights and
colors and he's
oh dinosaurs oh rocks oh how much should
it cost
so every ticket i want to say was that
venue's seats maybe like 60 bucks a seat
something like that so that's been used
seats between 2500 and 3000 i believe
yeah so i think there was 2 000 there
um
and i believe the tickets were something
like
um
something like 50 60 70 bucks something
like that so we're in like a hundred and
twenty thousand
and he played four shows in a row um
that weekend and then he went to the
next city so it was our like no he had
done eight shows or he was doing
something like that so it was like some
crazy like thing where i was like oh wow
this weekend they made whatever 800
grand
um and yeah the tickets tickets
basically range from like you know 60
bucks to 90 bucks
and um and the place is lit by the way
so like you know he comes on stage kids
go crazy he's like
you know he'd be like you know what does
the bubble do and everyone's like pop
and he's like when i say pop can you say
pop and like so it's like not like a
quiet show like because kids are loud
anyways so some kids just not paying
attention
like my daughter during intermission was
like i want to watch blippi on youtube
and so we like had to open up youtube on
our phone and give it to her during
intermission because she couldn't like
go five minutes without stimulation and
so it's and then they have like the
merch and the like the concessions they
have like all that right so it's
like pretty dope actually
and i was like wow this is kind of
genius they just took youtube ip and
this is this guy who was there was not
blippi the guy on stage was just some
you know theater kid who like didn't
make it you know and it's like all right
plan b i'll be i'll be blippi and um and
so it was like
they took the ip but they made their own
show out of it and so i started looking
into this and there's a company that
does this called vstar entertainment
awesome so vstar what they do is they go
license these kids brands and then they
put on kids broadway basically and they
tour around the country awesome and so
uh and blippi's just a guy with a guitar
right or were there more tournaments no
guitar he's just just him he just
watched so were there any instruments or
was it just like a soundtrack just
soundtrack and like lights and like uh
stage props so yeah so he he always kind
of like
like you know if they came out as sharks
like a bunch of like little backup
dancers came out as sharks and then they
whatever like that's an awesome mini
theater show right and so
v star entertainment they do another
brand that you've probably heard of call
or you may have heard of called paw
patrol it's basically another kid's
cartoon so guess how much
this is my like kind of triangulation
guess how much they sold in paw patrol
tickets last year just take a take a
guess
20 20 mil 40 million dollars
40 million dollars in event tickets in
event tickets for and that's just the
tickets not the murder that was just
last year and 22. uh i don't know it's
like this is like the just before
coveted numbers so like
2019 2020 something like that wow so
they got bought by cirque du soleil so
first so the back story is some guy
decides oh you know what like he's
watching sesame street he's like sesame
street should do a live show
and he goes and he basically raises 500
grand from this guy he mortgages his
house gets an extra 25 grand out of his
home equity so he's got 525 thousand
dollars he goes and he gets the license
to sesame street he started with the
sesame street show and then muppets and
like you know but that must have been
years ago this was like 1980 something
like that yeah
and then
um this other guy was doing it they
merged and then that whole thing gets
bought by cirque du soleil last year is
it cirque du soleil by the way like
guess how much cirque du soleil revenue
was have you ever read a cirque show no
i've not but i do know that the guy who
started it uh is a canadian guy he's a
billionaire i read dan blizzarian's book
and they talk about that guy a lot i
think he's like i mean he started a
circus so he's like
or yeah he's really eccentric and wild
and everything so it made him a
billionaire how much revenue does it
make
um ben have you been to a cirque du
soleil show cirque du soleil did a
billion does a billion dollars a year in
revenue which is insane
10 a five or ten percent of all las
vegas tourists
go to a cirque show when they're in town
is that what
what's that cirque is that the
is that
they have like 10 shows right it'll be
like they have oh and then they have
zoomanity they have like whatever and
the beatles yeah i know all about it and
i'm i'm into it and it's publicly traded
or at least it was before it was
acquired by private equity right private
equity owns it now and um
and it's a pretty badass business the
idea was do a circus but no animals so
it was like only human performers and to
do that they did like crazy acrobats and
like great costumes it's basically its
own genre at this point though right and
so he built that thing into a real
juggernaut and so cirque then bought
blue man group and v star entertainment
and so they got blue man which is like
an ad they what they had said was like
we do 10 million in ticket sales a year
for cirque du soleil blue man adds
another 2 million and then um
and then v star adds another 2 million
but they're all like different ticket
prices but like
they do 14 million in tickets uh sold
per year and so this this like live
entertainment thing really has caught my
attention because
i think as the world moves more and more
digital
the the like the demand for like these
one-off experiences like hey let's get
out of the house and go do something i
think it's just gonna keep going up
music festivals that's a winner
and then there's like uh i think plays
and musicals are gonna be a winner i
think they're gonna be bigger than they
were before even though the world was
digital and in fact because the world
moves digital what do you think about
all this i 100 agree and so earlier
today i sent you a notion doc of some of
my notes on i'm interested in peer
businesses which is basically like you
pay money and you're part of a club and
you meet up with them and i i can't talk
too much about what the names of the
companies were but they were doing like
uh one of them does a hundred million a
year in profit and it's basically two or
three meetups a year and there's
executives paying fifty thousand dollars
a year to be part of them and i think
actually these are gonna completely boom
i think conferences right now are
interesting but those are really hard
this actually seems way easier to pull
off um
all types of meetups airbnbs i'm 100 on
board that i think that in person is is
the move
yeah i and i think that so then i
started thinking like what are the other
opportunities and so i think a you could
just like go compete with these guys on
like either the same brands or other
brands so like what they did was
the v-star guy took tv ip turned it into
a live show the blippi guy is doing is
taking youtube ip and turning it into a
live show and i think you could just
even do this for more so like i think
you could even do like
we've talked about religion which is the
greatest free ip in the world so i think
somebody could do this for religion
which would make it extremely
kid-friendly in fact kid-focused
like christianity show basically i think
you could do this for dinosaurs or
science as a generic genre because like
if kids love trucks and dinosaurs or
whatever and you could just basically
create the like
the show you know day with dinosaurs or
something like that and once you get
like if you have a certain level of
quality
moms will spread this and they will talk
about it and they will like in their
mommy groups they will help you sell
these tickets
and um
and i just feel like there's a like it's
not that hard like you build one show
and you sell that one show a thousand
times right like the show goes on tour
mamma mia has made like i don't know
some stupid amount of money just being
the same show on tour with replacing the
the low-cost actor yeah anytime i'm
trying while we're talking i'm trying to
find the numbers so we used to so we did
events but we would do like these this
thing called hustle con which was like
our big one where like thousands of
people would come but then we do this
thing called 2x and 2x was basically
from like 7 p.m to like 10 p.m and it
was basically we got 15 or 10 women
all who were in tekken business not that
many of them were like well known but
they would have 10 minutes to like tell
a story and we would charge like 25 but
then we would get tens of thousands of
dollars in sponsors but we got to the
point where we could pull this off like
kind of like almost weekly in other
cities and when we started doing this
the hustle wasn't that popular but we
were making like i think like 30 grand a
night when we were doing it
and we had one employee running it right
and
she would use a team of contractors and
then we wouldn't supply anything like i
think we had free wine but i don't know
i don't even think it was free i like we
wouldn't supply anything but then we
have corporate sponsors and we crushed
it and in my head i'm like i can always
fall back on this to make a living
because it was so much easier than
people thought right
[Laughter]
yeah that's pretty good for a tech bro
um a tech bro business like all of you
you you were running one of the best
like women's entrepreneurship events
yeah because you got labeled wrong dude
yeah they're i'm like an onion man
there's layers so but basically like we
used to do this thing called pizza and
40s where we would do a meet up and i
would interview someone and they would
drink a 40 ounce and when the 40-ounce
beer was done the talk was done but then
like women were like this is like
there's all dudes here and so we created
like a like a wine version and that had
like way better it was like like cheese
and wine i don't even remember but that
had way better engagement and so we're
like oh like let's pursue this vein like
this there's clearly an opportunity here
until we created 2x which uh comes it's
like 2x chromosomes which i thought was
clever i stole it from reddit uh but
anyway we would do
i think we did 10 or 12
uh in one year and every single time it
was like 20 and 30 grand and the cost
the cost was nothing the cost was
renting the venue which cost like three
thousand dollars and we would make like
20 grand but you also you had readers in
every city right so that's how you sold
the tickets is that yeah yeah but we
weren't basically the speakers sold the
tickets the reason why we had 15
speakers was was i was like i bet each
15 will get 25 people to come plus our
like a little bit of our engine like
this is easy and you weren't making the
money off the tickets you're making
enough sponsors really anyway the
tickets
the business model was the tickets paid
for the event and then the conference
was all or the sponsors were all the
profit but when it's there's two things
going on one like women so whenever you
have like an underserved community like
sponsors definitely are willing to pay
more and two it was like a b2b component
so it wasn't kid's component which i
think would alter the economics but my
point of it is that i think that it was
far easier than people thought and it
was way more rudimentary and raw than
people thought and it worked we just
used splash that i think if you google
like 2x the hustle you'll like see like
the splash that is basically eventbrite
it was nothing special and it freaking
worked
that's dope um all right what else we
got
um all right uh let me uh i just got
kicked out of the document all right i
got it so one thing tell me what you
what you think about this
one thing that i've been doing as i'm
now starting to like get back into the
game uh or thinking about it so i've
been setting up calls with bankers so
bankers which i didn't even know what
those were bankers when someone wouldn't
like sarah my wife went to japan
yeah and she would like i would always
make her friends were like yeah like i
uh you know i'm a banker i work at a
bank i'm like oh which branch
uh and so bankers are basically people
who help people sell companies and help
people buy companies and when you sell a
company for like anything north of
probably 50 million they likely have a
banker and i've been contacting bankers
and my pitch to them is this hey i'm
thinking about starting a company in
this space you've sold a few companies
in this space tell me everything about
why
the this company was bought as well as
what the opportunities are that the
buyer what they were looking for
and uh maybe in five or ten years i'll
let you sell my company and i've been
able to line up meetings doing this
and it's
genius and
um
i've been a part of one or two of those
types of conversations and i was like oh
wow these guys are like vaults filled
with gold
so much bankers need podcasts like why
are they why are these guys not talking
well they can't so much info no but they
talk like generally speaking they don't
they can't talk about any specific deal
but like
they know a lot dude and they actually
know everything it's like you're you're
accountant it's like accountants you
know everything yeah they know
everything and they've been telling me
so much information so i like they'll
like basically they'll say here's why
this company was doing well here's why
it was succeeding here's why they bought
it and i'm like all right great what uh
what other companies was that buyer
trying to buy and why and they're like
well they always struggled with blank
and i'm like boom thank you and then
i'll say like um you sold three
businesses in the same space which one
was more fun to run
and so like for example i'll give you
i'll give you a concrete example the
business that i'm interested in now
we've talked about a bunch it's like a
vistage so which is basically a peer
group so companies that it's like a
group of 10 or 40 people who all have a
similar job title and they meet together
and they discuss their problems and it's
like a safe space to discuss you
can't talk about the internet and some
of them do huge one of them i can't say
which does over 100 million in profit a
year and they're just like meetups in
real life and i'll just be like well
what job titles was uh
gartner or whoever buys these companies
what job titles are they trying to get
to and they're really struggling to uh
to reach and they'll just tell me i'm
like oh great i can create a community
around that and i think i could build it
to sell it which what i want to know
from your perspective is that even a
good plan building to sell so part of me
is like yes it's clear path to make
money another part is like it's kind of
lame though
yeah well i think where you're at now
let's take three three options
build to sell
that which is basically optimizing for
like oh is there a sort of like a flip
is there a
is there a buyer on the other side of a
business like this
another one is build to win which is
basically like
um
for example when i talk to these bankers
what i'm trying to figure out is
what which of these businesses is like
not a special snowflake where it's like
oh
that's actually like a rinse and
repeatable model like i didn't like
that founder didn't like catch lightning
in a bottle at the perfect time and it's
their perfect background and they got
really lucky about this one thing it's
like oh those i don't want to emulate i
want to emulate the one where it's like
hey i think somebody could start that
same business today and do equally well
or do do just as well in this one
adjacent space and like you don't need
to be a genius uh with that and so
that's the second part of it which is
like build to win it's like optimizing
for something that's going to work
and then there's the last one which is
sort of like
you know build for fun or build for
mission which is like
go for something that like you something
you would never want to sell
that you're willing to do even if it's
low likelihood of success i think we all
know the answer is to do that bucket
right like i think
the question is like
how many how much security do you need
before you go do the thing you know you
should do
well or it could be a combination of
authoring like it could be like you
enjoy winning or you enjoy this space
and you want to make it successful but
there's a great clip from you and uh
what's uh free what's what's uh all in
david freeburg there's a great clip that
i shared that you and him had where he
basically said that founders
always sell themselves short and they go
for these small ideas because because
they think it's more reasonable but when
doing that
they kind of screw themselves because
it's actually easier sometimes to do
much of grander bigger ideas because
that attracts the crazy types of people
who you want to work with um you're
interested in competitive
not every joe is going to try to you
know do it like you know going and
trying to you know start a
railroad business or whatever versus an
fba business it's like well they're both
going to take all your time so that's
equal money well you're gonna go have to
go raise money from investors one will
let you just raise you're still gonna
get the money you need from investors
just one you maybe raise more at a
higher valuation and the other one
you'll raise less at a lower valuation
right like but did you agree do you
agree with him
i i do agree with him and i've thought
this for a very long time i remember uh
back in the day did you ever hear about
this thing called the unreasonable
institute i don't even think this is
around anymore that's a great name it's
sort of like the same guys who did
summit it's not it's not actually the
same guys but it's the same it was like
the same idea it was like right the
unreasonable institute was basically
this like it was based on this one word
unreasonable in the way that the hustle
is built on this one word hustle and uh
trans is built on one word trends and so
the unreason was it was exactly that it
was like
it's going to take unreasonable people
to do unreasonable things for the world
to move forward and it was like very
inspiring and then they met with all a
bunch of people a bunch of people who
did that the sort of elon musk types who
went and did unreasonable things and
then you start to look at it and you're
like
you know all things equal
um
you know i guess like your inputs are
sort of the same it's just your time and
energy and then like the outputs can be
very very different because
the inputs aren't the same because it is
possible to build something pretty cool
and not work that hard
but it's kind of impossible to build
something huge and not work very hard
all right who do we know and let's do
real examples i'm not saying it's not
true but who do we know that's building
successful awesome businesses without
working too hard
well
how about suli i actually don't know
what's his schedule does he grind
constantly
he works hard yes he works hard
so then no one you don't we don't know
anyone but
you and me like maybe i'll give you one
nuance on it he got there faster than
the normal person so like it looked like
it came easier but that's just because
he was better it wasn't because he
worked like he he wasn't putting in a
tenth of the hours he was putting in the
same number of hours and getting there
ten times faster which is i just think
that like there's a world where you have
business a and it doesn't grow nearly as
fast and you're working 40 hours a week
and then you have business b that's
growing significantly faster and you
have to work 100 hours a week like that
that is a reality yes that's true that's
what i'm talking about i'm not talking
about like very little i'm talking about
normal versus not normal there's also
things like this podcast or like people
who have like newsletters or blogs or
something like that where it's like or
they teach a course it's like you know
like unless you take your buddy neville
right so
neville i don't think you and me
well because but i'm doing multiple
things right so it's like on each one
i'm not putting in as much time but like
overall i'm working harder and if i
didn't do those other things
that one thing would just expand in time
i would just do more i would say wait
how often are you working now a day
normal work hours
uh not normal hours but
i work like a
the equivalent of eight hours a day got
it just not all to it not not all
continuously all right but back to what
was the original point
so my my point was like
uh is it
is this really true that you can kind of
like chill and win
and like no i i didn't mean
to say
i mean chill less or sorry chill more
work less
okay wait so then bro if you agree with
friedberg which i think i do
why are you
not going after like one big grand thing
like i started a newsletter that's not
exactly like
you know that's not like
world changing entirely it's neat but i
would put it on a six out of ten in
terms of like
maybe a five in terms of like big ideas
right
yeah i i agree with you the
reason why is because to me it's not a
bigness contest
it's a do i have a clear picture of what
i want like my life to be
and then can i like do i have a crystal
clear picture and then can i make that
happen
and it's like knowing what i want and
then getting what i want and so what i
wanted was not to work the hundred hours
right even though i even though i agree
like
that's cool it's fun and if i did do it
um i do think there's all these extra
benefits you'd get amazing talent to
come join you you'd make a bunch of
money you'd uh have a bunch of fun like
there's there's great benefits if i did
the big one the the big big big one but
i decided that like what i wanted yeah
yeah what i wanted more was more like
the
40 hour
a week
but hours spent on doing these types of
things like i love teaching teaching's
not the most
it's not the most like
world-changing unreasonable institute
style you know like let's go land a
rocket on mars type of idea but i have
the most fun doing it so i'm just
optimizing for like a different thing
rather than bigness i'm optimizing for
like you know my own enjoyment and so
that's why i'm not going after that so i
need things that are sufficiently
interesting
so that i'm interested and big enough so
i don't feel like i'm wasting my time
but like
it's not maximally big
right i feel you well to wrap up the
bank thing i think it's it was it's been
kind of interesting i'm going to
continue doing it maybe i'll uh uh i
didn't ask these people who i spoke with
today if i could talk about what we
discussed so i'm not going to bring it
up but uh
very useful i sent you the notes they
were cool they're great and also this
technique
um whether it's a specific technique or
a similar technique it's like there are
people who just know a lot of things
um you know people who invest other
people's money uh accountants bankers
people like um
you know vcs are like this they see they
see hundreds and hundreds of businesses
a year and so it's like
those people if you want to like speed
dial your learning you can go to them
and you can get basically free learning
off of off of them alright that's it
that's the episode
[Music]
you